[Music]
centimeter for centimeter the multi-ton
backhoe is moved into position but good
isn't good enough on the fairgrounds for
site manager - Mustafa he is on hand to
make sure everything is on the up and up
as a difficulty we have to work link for
link each of them has a logo we have to
make sure they're upright and level
LeapPad doesn't leave anything to chance
they've been working for years on their
presentation at the bow ma the world's
largest fair for construction machinery
in Munich so mining get it this one's
designed for mining it weighs 400 tons
and can assume different roles in the
quarry or be used in different types of
mines gold mines diamond mines and
copper mines for example hopefull
meaning Lipa has rolled out 67 of their
construction vehicles including the
largest highest payload capacity haul
truck in the world the t 282 its wheels
alone are four meters in diameter with
machines this big even full-grown men
let out their inner child
Nick Bellamy has 35 specialized driver's
licenses for construction vehicles he
will demonstrate the t 282 s tipping
function it takes around 12 seconds for
the bed to raise into position when it's
under a full load and then about eight
seconds to lower it
[Music]
off you go thank you some cows up you
can buy this one starting at a million
dollars
Lala has over 2800 horsepower and can
transport 200 tons we make a smaller
version in care store the team being cut
off leap has kicked off factory 100
kilometers west of Munich leaf has
smaller construction vehicles are being
put through their paces the smaller
version of the t28 e2 features a special
joint between the driver's compartment
and the truck bed
matías Hertzog is an engineer and
production leader and killed off
sometimes he likes to take leap as
vehicles for a test drive drives a bit
differently because of the joint it's
not like a normal vehicle you have to be
used to it and of course the 370
horsepower 560 Covey
each construction vehicle also needs a
hydraulic system hydraulic bar arms
provide the power for gripper arms and
truck beds in kicked-off they need
around 40,000 per year this is a dream
job for many men construction vehicles
fascinate lots of boys from an early age
it's fascinating to see how you can move
tons of material as if there were light
as a feather the gripper arm was custom
made most of leap has vehicles are
tailored to meet each customer's demands
and that requires teamwork double check
that it was properly mounted and that
the hoses are right those are some of
the practical problems our workers deal
with daily we're not a typical assembly
line backhoe manufacturer we make each
piece individually that's our strength
we're sending four of these to the
bomber this backhoe will also be making
an appearance at the bow ma trade fair
the leap ham 918 with a price tag of two
hundred thousand euros it's a big seller
in Europe but Li pair has its sights set
on new markets for its vehicles
it's hoping the bow moe will open the
door to new customers in the developing
world